foreign
[Music]
work and workplaces are changing at a
growing Pace challenging both leaders
and employees to adapt
these changes raise questions about what
it takes to succeed as an employee a
leader a team and an organization
what can we as Leaders do to facilitate
Excellence throughout the organization
it's clear that fostering excellence in
our organizations requires us to create
and maintain an Engaged and high
performing Workforce yet study after
study shows that employee disengagement
in low morale are rampant in most
organizations
research shows that to engage and retain
top talent workplaces must focus on
employees development their sense of
purpose in providing ongoing feedback
and direction
this calls for a shift from a
transactional model of manager as boss
or a command and control managerial
style to a more transformational model
of manager as coach
when managers utilize a coaching style
to lead they are better positioned to
manage the high interdependence required
to accomplish complex tasks as they
build and maintain the relational
foundations needed for an organization
to thrive in complexity
throughout this course you will expand
your leadership toolkit to include key
coaching skills that you can use to
support employees professional
development and Inspire in them a sense
of purpose and meaning at work
by doing so you can begin to build a
coaching culture that is grounded in
collaborative problem solving and
achieve your goals of organizational
excellence
ways to evoke insights and effectively
managing difficult conversations
in addition you will expand your sense
of self-awareness your ability to take
the perspective of others and your
awareness of how situation or context
impacts the interactions you have with
those you lead
the modules we designed for you combine
a variety of readings and videos with
experiential exercises so you practice
your coaching competencies and make them
an integral part of your leadership
toolkit
we're excited to lead you through the
course so that you can develop your
coaching skills and become a more
effective leader